I couldn't get any entry-level job in my
own company because I couldn't pass the
write written test or the math test for
the two disciplines I couldn't I own the
whole [ __ ] thing and the scrape facts
are I could not work for my own company
in an entry-level job
[Music]
we always successfully in everything but
school didn't do own school poor
terrible actually haunted it
you
and this is where I give my parents
enormous credit education is the way out
for immigrants my mom recognized that I
was a merchant an entrepreneur and then
when I got these enough she punished me
even though she knew I didn't need
school in her heart she made me know
that there was accountability for dicks
the biggest problem right now is
insecurity everybody's actions are to
get [ __ ] to close their insecurity we
have so much time and everybody's in
such a rush they're in a rush because
they want to prove something to somebody
money is not the variable of happiness
to me life is broken down into
complaining and not so if you're not
complaining well then I've never I've no
advice for you I'm pumped like you did
it I just don't understand people
dwelling and complaining like listen I
really really really would have enjoyed
being the quarterback of the New York
Jets but by fourth grade I looked around
I'm like [ __ ] I'm not gonna be the
quarterback of the jacks and so I said
you know what instead of being the
quarterback in the Jets I'm gonna buy
the Jets there's so many people they're
talking [ __ ] about how big of an
entrepreneur they're gonna be and how
much they're gonna achieve and they
don't work on weekends the reason I do
the only blog on YouTube is don't listen
to what I'm saying watch what I'm doing
I want to make patience and empathy and
gratitude and eating [ __ ] [ __ ] for
15 years
cool mmm period because that's the only
way they're gonna get it right you know
I worked every Saturday of my 20s like I
don't sit in my couch and say I'm gonna
be a millionaire and they're like
jerk-off all and playing that and all
that like people want all these special
things to happen but then they're acting
like everybody else and that gets into
this Saturdays up in your 20s like or or
just like taking risks or things of that
nature like the shit's [ __ ] binary
either you do the [ __ ] that gets you
there or you don't
and everybody's focused on the finish
line not the treadmill work and the
[ __ ] clicking the
aglet rocky [ __ ] balboa they don't
want to do that [ __ ] so what should we
do Gary V people should [ __ ] stop
complaining right people the [ __ ] they
are you got to figure out how to try
[ __ ] like that's like like you just
never know what your favorite food was
until you try if you only had chicken
you might have not known that hotdogs
were the best so that's what I love
about the Internet these kids have so
much option to like watch it on YouTube
and it said like my only answer to me or
anybody like it's just like try [ __ ] the
reason most people who are listening
right now we're not doing that thing is
they're worried about the opinion of
somebody usually their mother usually
their father and the reality is is that
your spouse may be the person holding
you back and you have to have that
conversation do you feel like you judge
yourself I don't and it's what I want
for everybody else we're beating
ourselves up like everybody sucks at
something right like we all have
shortcomings and we all have strengths
and for me it's like why don't we just
audit that you have to love hard you
have to love eating [ __ ] you have to
love people leaving comments saying you
suck yeah you have to love the process
figure out what your [ __ ] thing is and
stop making [ __ ] [ __ ] excuses who
the president is your mom did this like
like I missed it I had that idea for
uber then why didn't you [ __ ] do it
dick people decide no before they try
you just decided no because the system
tells you now you've been pound even
solo if you're lucky enough right now to
be listening and you're good at what you
like become tunnel [ __ ] vision because
there's way too many voices telling you
what and how I want the pain I want the
process I have the patience I don't care
what I have setbacks I know that I'm
asking for something special and if
you're asking for something special
it should be hard everybody's saying now
I just say yes
and then if it's a no I don't give a
[ __ ] for you to judge me that I lost I
don't know what do you think and that's
why I get soul into that because I'm
then you're not scared to try [ __ ]
because when you'll give a [ __ ] what
anybody says about you failing you love
family I love music own your
shortcomings own your strengths surround
yourself with the other [ __ ] and stuff
starts to
Thank You gravity
[Music]